I feel funny like when I used to climb
the rope in gym class peg hey Garth
what's happening
I can't believe Wayne is 20 months
awesome only surreal 21 years as in 21
seconds
I did a show I sound like show business
now album with Mickey Rooney he was 62
at the time and he said to me I was 25
two weeks ago I never forgot that
different generations in America places
across the world this was before I did
Waynesville and and Masai warriors would
come out of the bush nude but wearing an
elephant t-shirt and my sort of thought
is that if I were to go back there now
it would be a Waynesville t-shirt
ultimately if there's kind of a
emotional thing about it it's just the
guys who have nothing in town
like they have a name see face they live
with their parents or clearly the
happiest people in town so it just feels
good there's a classic underdog it's
like you know confections it's it's fun
you know that it may not be entirely
nutritious but it's it's a peculiarly
sort of American thing it looks like fun
and it is fun such an honor to be part
of the movie that I didn't think it was
going to get made and then I didn't
think they were going to release it and
then I didn't think it was going to do
well and I didn't think necessarily that
remember it but it's just been an
amazing gift that just keeps on giving
and I'm so proud and grateful for this
evening and grateful that people want to
see it and they liked it this movie has
become such a global part of of
everybody's experiencing for Europe